so obviously you uh you end up for you
the Catalyst to start writing and like I
guess everyone kind of you said you had
a pub deal that you had to get bought
out of right so what was like your first
initial like real step into being in the
quote-unquote music industry like how
did you get that initial Pub deal like
before we really knew who you were you
know what I'm saying uh
[__] I uh
okay around like it was like 2019 2020.
that's when I met uh my manager okay and
remember he was like bro start writing
yes so when I met him I was like making
like 10 hooks a week bro like we still
in Philly yeah I was in my the same room
just in the crib at the crib
make sure you're like cutting the hook
sending them to him and then yeah he's
doing his job he's sending it out yeah
so it's like I was made like 10 10 songs
a week
yeah at that time I was close to my man
produced my producer the new the nuzo
and I started making a lot of Beats on
his a lot of hooks on his a lot of hooks
on his Beach yeah and he was about to
get signed um but the person he was
about to sign to they're like who they
on the hooks
like you know what I'm saying he hard so
that's how like
that's how that happened with my first
Pub dealership and now when they ask
who's that on the hook they keep you on
the hook yeah they keep they keep me now
now they're like oh that's the yeah it's
Friday sure yeah we're gonna need that
come over here how in demand are you in
terms of just like artists trying to get
you on their [__] and how selective are
you being with that because a lot of
people burn out pretty quick when it
comes to oversaturating
yeah it's like
I look at every situation like dude
what do I do for both of us and then
they like do a benefit me
or sometimes about the music crew like
in fact it sounds amazing sounds amazing
I'm [__] with you but it's like I'm
down to work with whoever bro like it
just gotta make sense for the both of us
you know what I'm saying like at the
same time I'm giving my own my own
my own music yeah you know what I'm
saying so it's not like I'm building the
I already built a fan base so it's
probably harder for you to give away
hooks at this point because you're like
I mean that could that could be my [__]
yeah but I I make so much music there's
more where that came from yeah it's like
I got like 500 that I'm not using that's
why I say with the great ones the great
ones aren't greedy because there's just
more with that yeah I'm gonna just write
another one tomorrow so go ahead take it
like it's gonna help us out like it's
gonna help us picture the program like
in like my music like I say
and the music I dropped like on my
projects lost the melody and [__]
it's a very distinctive sound like
so like a lot of [__] I make up like
things that's not for me I just give it
to somebody else you kind of know what
I'm saying yeah you don't fit in my
album so everything I make for me is
like a hundred percent for me yeah so
like say I'm working on an album
I'll make 14 songs and all 14 songs
going over
you know what I'm saying like I'm not
making I'm not even finishing the song
right for me and it's not you know what
I'm saying so I got like 500 just songs
that I wouldn't drop right I could give
somebody sure it's a nice problem to
have no for sure
um we know Chris Brown's on the album
anybody else on the album I'm sure
there's tons of features let's be honest
but can you share any what is driving
what do you want us to drop it where you
can talk about the features
we could drop it whenever oh uh
when you when you dropping the tracklist
like a week before so good I got um
I got the The veto on the tracklist
shout out to him yeah my man Fireboy and
by the way David O is how you say his
name oh yeah I say the video I thought I
thought listen I interviewed him and I
watched a bunch of interviews with him
from Africa and they were saying David
oh so when I said David oh he was like
you said my name right and I was like
man I was like yes because I thought it
was Davido
man you got that [__] afrobeat Gods
right now that that taliban's is going
crazy right now yeah I got them boys on
there who else on there
in Maverick City I don't know I'm not
familiar with Matthew it's a gospel
group it's like a choir oh fire I got
them on the intro they it's crazy over
Penny rappers nah no rappers wow I might
I might throw somebody on like a remix I
had I had some rappers I wanted on there
but you know what I'm saying time is
timing
um
well hopefully you don't like some
remixes it's crazy yeah I like so is is
the afrobeat song is everybody on the on
the same song or do you have multiple I
got multiple fire yeah that's like
that's like my um second home like music
wise I ain't gonna cat because I'm
Haitian so
that like afro will be feeling is just
in me it's the funny genre it's like
finally there's music that people can
dance to happening like on a mainstream
level you know for sure it's like the
best part of the club night is when like
DJ yeah because people are having fun
they're saying about it's like shout out
to March Madness I love it but I've been
hearing it for like 10 years it's like
yeah I could pop bottles to that but
like I'm not gonna dance to it enough
so for you like uh let's break that
because because you're one of the hook
guys now who would you say is like a
Mount Rushmore of the best hook man of
all time who's the hook gods
my hood Gods Nate Dogg Nate Dogg is I
feel like Undisputed top number one slot
right yeah
I'm gonna go to um
a little Chris Brown
yeah of course I go to Ty Dollar shout
out to Ty
and then I'm gonna go to at the tie
I'm gonna go to Sanford
oh yeah like not even though he did a
lot of hooks but but the ones he did
[__] everybody album up tip I'm on right
now like I think back to uh the video of
like when wallow met him and like yeah
and I just remember being like damn I
really need to dive into this kind of
[__] catalog if he's making grown man
cry out here he's making real music bro
like
a lot of [__] be overshadowed but
the music the real music we put in the
back a lot nowadays but when you tap in
like a [__] like Sanford that [__]
special bro